yeah I don't welcome to this video
playing my way so yeah yes replace the
science stuff put into V 6 a-6 and then
G success and some stuff like that or
this one okay yeah I don't know here no
don't know things here I think it plays
some f5 f5 set up here right we need to
and then f5 or something okay so chief
1g5 and cannot just checkmate am
unfortunately huh we've got a good
center here let's see how this works out
if this kind of Center can be very
strong but also also be quite weak I
mean he has twin g5 check app you can
play 25 and take on g2 a booby an
extremely cheeky but okay it didn't do
it um young I think f form I would
really like to get some control over
those squares a good idea here would be
something or getting in something like
g3 and I also want to take care get what
the city piece I if I don't believe this
b5 just weakens black a lot slowly does
it okay
so taking this now 32 33 controlling the
lot of the dark squares and allowing
nitey to plan so that after be 492 I got
94 strategically speaking this position
is pretty bad for black with the bishop
and all the pawns on the wrong squares
but is a good tactical player won quite
a number of games against me from really
bad positions by tricking me
not quite sure what black should do now
94 next some cases g4 f5 is also
interesting but this is just by father
the most logical and centralizing
continuation
just support this now I'm not quite sure
how to continue here it looks very nice
I just don't have to make sure that
you're not falling for some wacky made
or film I could pile up rupee 50 p 1
also yeah Knight f3 Queen deform getting
the Queen to d4 is interesting there's
also this one and this is stopping the
porn from advancing
yeah that's good that's a good move
one of the Sun that that terrible bishop
becomes active yeah so b3 was bad check
I mean the position might still be okay
for me but I'm not happy with the bishop
being only for Karen made maybe white is
still fine now I can take you six don't
see why not okay so he'll retreat knight
c6 now and take their
okay seven assists coming in I wonder if
I just go a 4 here so it's also to trade
Queens this is interesting let's do it
if he doesn't take now on possum I think
I'm fending off his attack pretty good
pretty well and if you take I can i can
actually play with the eight I can play
with the end let's check this look at
eight assists okay it's still a good
move though check so no it's time
morning check now let's let's be good
here let's play play well let's take the
C file let's play that it's a kind of
statement with what your blunder stuff
usually maybe I should have played a
king up first I can do a really cool
before that never works
absolutely aware of getting us to get
into the porn but I can I mean he's also
not invading me that doesn't work
I have no time is the problem nite nite
down is to move I don't get to that
friggin a to pawn ok looks you won or
something doesn't work I think
[Music]
I still don't see how I'm winning this
looks like I'm making progress somehow
it not sure that i actually do taking
giving the exchanges at least easy for
me to play so I'm doing it probably not
the best continuation okay and
completely losing fresh air that's crazy
and I'm blundering the Sean unbelievable
game wrong ah well I agree coordinated
this position which was not so easy to
coordinate to a complete win and a solid
huh yeah and a four and so on
everything's okay right I mean okay what
was wrong sb3 I should do not play b3
here probably let that get an activity
of it but after a after this I mean I'm
just material up here ok and here ok
here i have to play king a true i mean i
just i just didn't do it I should just
clanking a true and this is the entire
belief because he cannot enter with the
King and I will win this porn long run
impossible for him to prevent you crooks
III before if I win da porn it's
probably a win the way it was it was
really tricky to play 96 maybe was
better I don't know
can't you see I was crazy had to allow
me that now of course it's winning for
white which I shouldn't of God given the
given the exchange it was so clear that
it is not the best move but I self i can
play clicker there but it's just
cleaning up the past move yes now i can
probably ma I am just promoting so we
have to go here and then this and over
weds honea he cannot really prevent me
from checking to access ok anyway thanks
for watching